in berlin und wittenberg ist gerade
kirchentag die evangelen laden zum
ringelpiez ohne anfassen und das im
lutherjahr 500 jahre reformation das
kann man mal feiern findet 23 millionen
euro kostet so ein kirchentag heutzutage
damit sie meine hausmarke haben dieses
jahr unter dem motto du siehst mich das
nicht das echte logos unbewusst sich
mehr bürger zugeht 23 millionen kostet
der kirchentag ein heidengeld sich bei
einer gesagt jetzt die gute nachricht
der steuerzahler also wir alle spendiert
über die hälfte
das internet von uns oder finde ich so
gesehen sollte das motto eigentlich
lauten du bezahlst mich ja dabei sind
gerade mal 27 prozent der deutschen
protestanten die größte gruppe sind die
hier jedoch die in die hölle kommen die
nicht konfessionell mit 36 prozent sind
die größte gruppe bezahlen mit ich
bezahle den kirchentag und zum dank darf
die merkel der wahlkampf machen ihr
gestern mit obama am brandenburger tor
was hat der typ die folge schleim du
zunächst mal muss ich sagen dass ich
nicht nur diese stadt liebe sondern dass
auch eine meiner liebsten partnerinnen
während meiner gesamten präsidentschaft
wir leben wie sie guckt bin meinte buhre
wahlkampfhilfe oder wie er sagen würde
obamacare etwas
ja ich habe mich was hat das bitte mit
dem kirchentag zu tun
ihre umfragewerte sind auch so schon gut
genug erschreckend gut wie ihm wenn die
märkte der weg ist aus der bibel gelesen
hätte zu dessen zitiert die frau das
grundgesetz denn das kennt sie auswendig
oder mieter soll ist artikel 1 unseres
grundgesetzes die würde des menschen ist
unteilbar und deshalb beides ist richtig
verstehen beides ist richtig aber nur
eins davon steht ihm konnte